on February 28 1953 two scientists at
the University of cambridge's Cavendish
laboratory found the secret of life
Francis Crick and his young American
assistant James Watson discovered the
structure of DNA and for that they would
go on to win the Nobel Prize
but they couldn't have done it without
help that help came from Rosalind
Franklin a 32 year old physical chemist
who was little known outside of
scientific circles but here's the thing
it was her research that point in Watson
and Crick in the right direction Watson
had glimpsed one of Franklin's x-ray
photographs of DNA which provided the
pivotal clue that helped determine DNA's
double helix structure the Twisted
ladder that gave rise to Modern
molecular biology
based on her notebooks it's clear that
Franklin was on the cusp of making the
discovery herself despite the critical
role she played she received no
recognition for her work Franklin was
determined to become a scientist at the
age of 12. and overcame all obstacles to
get there
England at the time did not exactly
favor women she was one of just 500
women accepted into the University of
Cambridge the quota set for female
admissions to ensure they didn't exceed
10 of the male undergraduate body she
pursued her studies in physical
chemistry amid the terror of the London
Blitz in World War II early in her
career she helped the war effort by
investigating how coal changed once
injected to heat using a methane called
x-ray crystallography
when x-rays are shown onto a crystal
they bounce off or diffract in specific
patterns by studying these patterns
scientists can determine the structure
of the crystal she used the same
technique to examine DNA which isn't a
typical Crystal but she managed to treat
it like one with the help of young
doctoral student Raymond Gosling they
shown x-rays on a tiny DNA strand the
thickness of a strand of hair for 100
hours at a super close range 15
millimeters in order to get a clear
picture Franklin's extra images of DNA
especially the iconic Photograph 51
displayed a distinctive x-shaped pattern
this pattern hinted at DNA's real shape
which resembled a spiral staircase or
Twisted ladder interpreting the image
required Franklin to perform
mathematical computations to analyze the
pattern in an attempt to reveal its
structure while Franklin was busy doing
just that at King's College London where
she worked Quicken Watson gained access
to her x-ray image how
Franklin's assistant Gosling showed the
work to the assistant head of the
biophysics unit at King's College London
Maurice Wilkins Wilkins was supposed to
be Franklin's supervisor but the two
didn't really get along then in January
1953 James Watson visited King's College
London and Wilkins showed it to his
friend in rival without Franklin's
knowledge or permission Wilkins didn't
realize the impact the photo would have
on Watson who later recalled the instant
I saw the picture my mouth fell open and
my pulse began to race
during dinner Wilkins went a step
further and gave Watson the necessary
dimensions of the DNA sample in photo 51
which was then used to develop the
structure of DNA
and then there was more Watson and Crick
later received an internal King's
College London research report
containing Franklin's unpublished
results about her DNA diffraction images
it was given to them by Max perutz a
Cavendish colleague who got his hands on
it during a visit to King's College as
Brenda Maddox writes in her biography
about Rosalind Franklin the MRC report
was all Watson and Crick could hope for
as valuable as an enemy's code book
from that report they determined that
the two strands of the DNA Helix must
run in opposite directions like two
escalators side by side one going up and
one going down
Franklin hadn't yet made this connection
but she was very close to figuring it
out her notebook reveals she was
contemplating whether DNA had a double
helical two-chain structure around the
time Watson and Crick got their hands on
her report Max per Roots defended
handing over the report to his Cambridge
colleagues quote I was inexperienced and
Casual in administrative matters and
since the report was not confidential I
saw no reason for withholding it he
later admitted he should have asked for
permission from Franklin as a matter of
courtesy
since the report wasn't confidential it
is possible Franklin knew that her
research had already made its way to
Cambridge regardless the Cambridge
scientists did not inform Franklin that
they were using her data given all that
she knew how could Rosalind Franklin
have missed connecting the dots herself
it boiled down to her personality she
was the kind of scientist who believed
in thoroughness she didn't want to jump
to conclusions based on one image DNA
exists in different structures notably
the a form and B form while Photograph
51 showcased the B form Franklin was
captivated by the intricate details of
the a form believing it held more
significant and yet unraveled insights
especially given the Richer data it
presented to crystallographers so she
temporarily set aside the now iconic
photo 51. it's something like being
handed the key to a treasure chest but
choosing to examine it closely to make
sure it works before using it Watson and
Crick didn't make that mistake they knew
what they had and quickly brought it to
the world's attention
on April 25th 1953 James Watson and
Francis Crick published a landmark paper
in nature proposing the double helix as
a long elusive structure of DNA a
discovery that earned them the Nobel
Prize in physiology or medicine a decade
later
in the final paragraph of their paper
they acknowledged that they had been
stimulated by a knowledge of the general
nature of the unpublished experimental
results and ideas of two scientists at
King's College London Wilkins and
Franklin
in 1958 Franklin died of ovarian cancer
possibly caused by her repeated exposure
to x-rays during her lifetime
she was just 37 years old
Franklin's early death also meant she
missed out on the Nobel Prize which is
not given out posthumously neither
Watson nor Crick mentioned her when they
accepted their Awards in 1962. though
Wilkins who also received the prize did
historians say there's no evidence
Franklin felt aggrieved by what happened
however she may have felt differently
had she lived long enough to read an
appallingly disrespectful book written
by Watson and published in 1968 in which
he admitted he and Crick used Franklin's
data without her knowledge writing Rosie
of course did not directly give us her
data for that matter no one at Kings
realized they were in her hands notice
how he wrote disparagingly of Franklin
calling her Rosie
and he wasn't alone in his casual
diminishment of her when Franklin
prepared to leave King's College for
birkbeck part of the University of
London Wilkins wrote to Crick our dark
lady is leaving us next week
over the years there has been a growing
recognition of the dark ladies
contributions to the discovery of the
structure of DNA with more people
championing her role in one of the most
significant scientific discoveries of
the 20th century finally giving her the
credit that she didn't get when she was
still alive
Franklin's work was heavily rooted in
scientific thinking you can practice
thinking with scientific principles with
brilliant a website and app where you
can learn through physical Insight by
solving puzzles and it's free for you to
try out there's something for everyone
whether you'd like to brush up on your
skills in math data science or computer
science there are no tests and if you
ever get stuck you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong
brilliant is part of my daily routine I
like to take a few minutes out of my day
to improve my analytical thinking skills
by going through their logic puzzles you
can try out brilliant for free for 30
days by clicking on the custom link in
my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my custom link
will get 20 off their premium
subscription which gives you access to
all the offerings
thanks for watching for newsthink I'm
Cindy Palm